their shares of people under 35 who
reported being engaged with their jobs
dropped from 37 to 33 4 not a big drop
but it's the lowest level since 2011. at
the same time the share who reported
being actively disengaged Rose from 17
uh 17 to 12. five percent that's a real
number on 17 to 12. remote and hybrid
work during the pandemic is a
significant factor in the growing
workplace
disgruntled men of younger generation
young workers aren't getting enough
social interactions mentorship and
guidance from their managers and more
experienced colleagues and remote and
hybrid work environments the rise of
digital messaging tools like slack has
also made it harder for early career
employers to learn by osmosis in an
office I wonder why companies can
improve the office experience reorganize
the workplace to create more space for
people to collaborate and socialize
organize more happy hours oh my God pay
for parking and Subway Place fairs by
the way this sounds can you find out who
the writer of this article is he she
sounds pissed off who is the writer what
what Aki is saying Aki's boss please she
is asking for a parking pass or a subway
fare like a you know money there to help
her out with allow people to arrive
later she wants to come later to work
yeah and leave earlier to avoid rush
hour commutes and help facilitate the
social interactions and mentorship the
young people are otherwise missing wait
a minute wait a minute how do you Pat
you are a big Mentor sorry to interrupt
but how how the hell do you get mentored
by showing up later and leaving earlier
no but you know what it is though this
is a crime what [__] is what this is
tell a younger person younger people
don't want to work that hard what yeah
how the hell you move up in a company
how the hell do you move up in your in
your career Adam yeah I think there's a
four-letter word that uh young people
need to understand that it's not a bad
word and that word is work yeah okay not
up in here no not up in here not up in
here
yeah I mean guys the reality is if
you're 20 years old you're gonna be
working
that four-letter word again work for the
next 50 years yeah okay for the next 50
years
now microwave success yeah okay it's a
slow burn [__] there's no like
oh let me just show up to the office at
10 o'clock leave by four check out get
the parking passes with my dog yeah yeah
that's not how it works yeah exactly
okay maybe they need like an
inspirational speaker or somebody that
they can look up to since the
transgender thing is becoming a big hit
maybe there was a famous poet okay for
the transgender community and he said
you better work you better work you
better work working
she better work
standings
listen to Rupaul didn't work you will
end up living in a van down by the river
yeah I think the Gen Z needs to realize
that work and work ethic is not a bad
thing yeah it's what's going to help you
survive for the next 70 years of your
freaking life yeah and if you're not
used to getting used to it now buddy
whether this recession happens or not
it's coming at some point so here's
what's crazy about what you're saying
right now Adam it's the next story which
is funny about this so let me let me
without ruining the story let me just
read it so one story Insider this tells
you who's writing for Insider and who's
writing for Wall Street Journal so The
Insider story is about don't work people
so hard here's a Wall Street Journal
story let's go bosses want hard workers
so they're hiring older people
by the way older people who have been
through recessions and they know they're
like you know this could get really bad
because I'm old and I've been through it
that's right you know what you better
put your head down and work you're gonna
get your ass shot off all the work all
the workers are increasingly in demand
at businesses as they're more likely to
have a strong work ethics show up on
time and value stability companies such
as KinderCare Learning Centers and
Manpower group have signed AARP pledge
to give workers over 50 a shot at hiring
people 55 and older are the fastest
growing segment of the workforce and the
trend is driven by demographic shifts
longer lifespans and a weak stock market
a Wall Street Journal uh nor a survey of
America's values found that
three-quarters of people 65 and older
said hard work is very important to them
personally compared to 61 percent 18 to
29 ageism remains a barrier for some
older workers but age discrimination
complaints to equal employment
opportunity commission dropped ready 45
from 2011 to 4 to 2021. hey normally the
older workers were afraid of being
replaced by the 23 year old hey 23 year
old you know what this article says to
you they're no longer scared of you
because you're lazy yeah you don't work
hard how much does that suck FYI just so
you know this as a kid growing up if I
you know how people say well my dad
always did this and my mom already
called me my mom called me Mora my dad
called me this you know what my dad
called me when I was a kid you're lazy
he said it thousands of times when I was
14 15 16. I was so sick of it and then I
said maybe this man is right and I went
in the Army I said you know what no I'ma
work my ass off then in a Marketplace
sits there and says you want to work
we're going to reward you we're going to
reward you Tom what do you have to say
about storyline not that you write you
you relate to the older people but yeah
what do you have to say about a story
like this
um we're seeing it and we're seeing it
and Pat and I are involved on a couple
companies and um and one's in the music
industry once in the insurance industry
and one's in media so this is pretty
diverse group and we are seeing people
that were sick and tired of maybe the
politics and the wokism a lot of things
of large organizations looking forward
to coming back to a mid-sized company
and bringing all their experience and
skills we are seeing interviews these
interviews have been unbelievable Pat
right we say well why do you want to do
this and do this because you guys
inspire me I love the youth that's here
I love the diversity that's here and so
for many of them they don't want to be
they don't want to be in that old
environment and they're here saying I'm
going to work hard I'm going to bring my
experience and I'd love to be part of
this because it kind of inspires me
again so 23 year olds you better be
careful because that's not that those
aren't you know practiced interview
questions that is the passion of their
heart and they're willing to come and
they're coming for your job I'll say
don't come no no
these older guys once they can figure
out how to turn their computer on yeah
they kill the game
but if you're giving a computer and say
hey get to work I got no clue about this
is so funny laptop Twitter
open Windows yeah so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]